[Music]
my point in 2012 to a lot of people was
you do understand there's an entire
generation right now being affected and
they're going to be 24 years old and
they won't know any different and that's
where we're living now in 2021.
[Applause]
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
gary fantastic to see on real vision
say my friend thank you
there's look there's a lot to talk about
firstly just for some people just a bit
of your background would be fantastic
how you got to where you are now and
then we'll dig into what you're really
up to now and where we're going you know
very classic um you know kind of
americana immigrant eastern european
story family is from belarus in the
soviet in the former soviet union
we immigrated here in the late 70s uh 78
december of 78 right before 79
very tough kind of first three four five
years you know studio apartments in
queens you know no cars walking five
miles to kmart
you know
scrapping
my sister was born
in the states the first year we were
here so it was just a very you know
hardcore
upbringing east coast queens dover
and then edison new jersey in 1982 where
i really kind of you know
started my american journey i would say
um
lived there for the next
eight years before i moved to another
part of new jersey
my dad during that time went from being
a stock boy in a liquor store to a store
manager to eventually buying his own
shop
i had very much discovered who i was in
addison new jersey lemonade stands
baseball cards shoveling snow
you know just incredibly intuitive
to entrepreneurship and selling and
buying and working it was as fun for me
to
work
you know
shoveling snow and washing cars as it
was to play sledding and playing
football or baseball so um
got into my teenage years started
working my dad's liquor store all the
time
uh because you know oldest son of a
first generation immigrant family as a
merchant
uh fell in love with people collecting
wine that was a big breakthrough for me
that people actually collected wine the
way i collected sports cards
and that started a you know 20-year
passion of mine to
build a large business for my parents i
was incredibly affected by
having a great mother
and
having a hard working father and i was
just extremely grateful
and i wanted to give back
and
i kind of knew in my late teens early
20s that i was talented in business i i
thought it i knew it
this is a very d you know you know this
this was a very different era the 90s
80s
entrepreneurship wasn't as accepted it
wasn't you know this was the golden era
of school and proper job that's right so
had a lot of adversity from
voices around me teachers other friends
parents i was a dnf student and being
told that i would never be anybody that
i was that was all about the credentials
at that point
that's right if you didn't have a degree
or whatever you were nobody
that's right and uh luckily i
had a mother who didn't make me feel
that way and that was enough
you know all the voices versus hers
and that and i also i also had a real
mission i really really wanted to
accomplish what i'm grateful that i was
able to which was have a substantial
impact on my family's business
and i did that and built my dad's
business from a four to a 65 million a
year business and
then kind of embarked on my own at 34.
you know
family businesses don't pay super well
so i didn't really make a lot of money
in my 20s and early 30s which is why a
lot of my content speaks about patience
i lived it i really didn't have a lot of
money
made some very smart investments with
the money i was able to save in those 13
years and facebook twitter and tumblr is
early
high-risk angel investments changed the
course of my career in a lot of ways um
and then my brother was graduating
college we wanted to do business
together and we decided
on a client service business which you
know at that point a lot of my smart
friends
including mark zuckerberg and others
thought was not a good idea
wasn't the highest way to make money
wasn't starting a vc firm wasn't
starting a company
but i was completely convinced that i
wanted to build a communications death
star as i called it
i wanted to build what is today now
vayner x you know a
global
mexico city singapore london new york la
over 1300 employee
multi-hundred million dollar a year
revenue business
that
really gives me a foundation v friends
which i'm sure we'll get into
you know empathy wines which was you
know a substantial
six to seven figure exit depending on
how the urnette works resi the
restaurant app nine figure exit
um you know and so
uh
excuse me empathy eight or nine figure
ex so you know i really i've built a
infrastructure that i think is going to
allow me to
um
continue to grow
and
having a business
at the size of vayner x and that the
profit that keep the vayner x kicks out
as a baseline as almost a sun while i
create a lot of satellite opportunities
where i develop talent
where i develop a totally different
religion of marketing
and attention arbitrage and
contemporary communication you saw that
early on right social media and the
power of it for marketing the rise of
the influence so you are super early in
all of that and i've been very
influential in other people i think in
that as well yeah if you read crush it
which i wrote in 2008 and came out in
2009 it's almost scary
how right it is about what ended up
happening with influencer marketing
you know it's very similar to you know
i'm starting to populate some of my 2010
11 tweets about virtual goods you know
farmville was enough for me to see
to believe in nfts it took an entire
full decade
before i got much louder about it but i
have incredibly
uh and this is you know i i i don't love
using the word luck because i think it
is then used as an excuse by people who
don't want to put in the work but
there is no question i've been gifted
lucky to be gifted with some uncanny
understanding of consumer behavior i
just
my friend if i told you how comfortable
i am with guessing what people are going
to do and how often that becomes true
it almost
scares me now i don't think the guessing
is really guessing it's that it's not
you put in your 10 000 hours right
you're an expert that's what you do
and even with that even with this nft
thing i mean i probably put in another
200 hours in in late december in
december through the first in the first
home
in the last month of 2020 in the first
hundred days of 2021 i spent almost
every hour i had on nft research
going backwards to why did larva labs
did what they did with punks
what was going on in every discord why
crypto kitties what was happening with
flo what are the other blockchains
besides ethereum what's been ethereum
what's ethereum been up to since i
bought it in 2016. like just really went
back and did a lot of homework before i
felt comfortable saying you know what
i'm going to talk on this
in a much more significant way and let's
see where this takes us now
let's start your crypto journey first
before we dig into all of this when did
that start you said you bought ethereum
when when did you start getting aware of
the space and what did you think it
meant then
and then how did that change as you
start to see nfts and the tokenization
of everything there was a very very very
in now looking back very bougie very
a-list very very illuminati group of
guys and gals that got together at south
by southwest
back in 2000
nah uh
2011 12 13 14 15 16 17 and it was we
called it the jam session
and
krasaka travis kalkanick founder of uber
ashton kutcher mark cuban
sophia girlboss uh and josh other people
maybe not as crazy names but msg and and
josh ellman and aaron battalion and on
and on and on and
aaron battalion
is the reason that i bought crypto so
early he was the former cto
of living social but he's a true
technologist you know like a real
technical nerd and you know and
in a jam session
geez you know uh quite quite a long time
ago
i listened didn't say goddamn word for
two hours as they talked about bitcoin
it was first time i'd heard of it and it
was just so over my head for a couple
reasons unlike you my friend even to
this day
my ability my knowledge
even my passion around currency and
let's say financier and financial
is quite low it doesn't it doesn't grip
me it is not my deep passion or
understanding it doesn't come natural to
me
even like the concepts of central
banking or trading currencies it doesn't
come natural to me um and i don't love
it
but i was very fascinated by this
concept of de-centralized servers it was
so profound at the time so that happened
i i bought some you know maybe six or
seven coins i can't even explain how low
it was it was just
nothing
i forgot about it
came back maybe a year or two later
maybe two years later jam session again
and this time aaron battalion tells me
about ethereum
and that really caught my attention
because i remember thinking bitcoin
was really cool and amazing and
obviously has gone on to become what it
became
and i thought of it as like okay that
needs to become a central brand like a
nike like gold like like god like school
like a diploma that's a harvard that's a
brand game and if it wins that brand
game that's gonna win and it by the way
it went on to do that yeah uh ethereum i
was like oh building on top of it and
like the scale and really i had these
almost like apple versus android
feelings about it i remember thinking
right oh bitcoin could go on to be apple
and ethereum could go on to being
android like a player for everything
else and so i was very bullish on that
and i bought a bunch of that i remember
right around that same time my brother
aj and i got a bunch of dogecoin like
for free or for a hundredth of a
hundredth of a cent and that was like a
period of being hot on it and and then i
would only check in when a tweet or an
article for the next two or three or
four years caught my attention i was not
going you know i was very deep in my
business i was very deep in in content
and social media arbitrage
it wasn't where i was spending my energy
i
crypto kitties caught my attention
later on
and i was like that really in the same
way that i'm very hot now the same
reason i'm like ooh collectibles and
trees
because and i think what's really
interesting about your story is you
didn't come at this from finance
you came with it seeing different stuff
and i think this is correct important
because this is i think where the future
lies
so cryptokitties you see that you're a
marketing guy and you start to think and
i start to think i know why people will
buy that
if this becomes like bitcoin
the difference between an nft and let's
say a currency is there's a social
signaling and a need to communicate it
that is by default when you say to
somebody
when you drive a mercedes benz or you
wear a rolex or you wear a four thousand
dollar pair of sneakers you don't have
to say something
to say something yeah when you're
sitting on 4 million or 40 million
dollars of bitcoin you have to say hey i
have you know and i put you in a curious
spot that's why cash is different than
assets
and i under and i understood that and
that came natural to me because humans
love social signaling it's a core part
of being a human
it's the poorest the you know like like
to me communication is what human beings
are completely predicated on it's why i
bet the farm on social media i knew i
knew there was no way we were gonna let
it be a fad
it's the same way that i know that nfts
will not be a fad now
much like social much like internet 95
when i first got in and launched
winelibrary.com in 96 and 97 which was
crazy early to launch a liquor stores
website this is my third cycle back to
pattern recognition 10 000 hours
my biggest concern is that i know 98
maybe even 99
of the current projects of nfts will be
negative investments for the people that
view them as long-term investments
you know i think that
i think that it's not sustainable around
supply and demand
and we haven't even seen the greatest
intellectual properties enter the space
properly we've not seen pokemon
go properly yet we haven't seen star
wars go pro
yeah disney disney go properly right and
so
and by the way not to mention most
sports outside proper football a little
bit was so rare and obviously the nba
with top shot but we still don't have
the nfl we have a baseball product on
wax which you know is okay and in soccer
they've got a bit on chili's and so you
know that's socio's project but you know
music i mean where's jay-z's first nft
or elvis presley so we are in the dawn
dawn dawn of all of this and people are
spending a lot of money on tokens on
intellectual property that has
a very high risk
outcome you know i i've i've jumped into
a couple of projects recently more
more because i just want to support
more diversity in the nft space you know
i'm really enjoying some of the
female-led projects some of the
minority-led projects i think it's
important
to because we you know collectively
you know i i get an incredible high my
friend on the email of hey you showed me
this world teaching someone how to fish
has been my life i enjoy it
and so you know it's tough though with
something this new because you're
yelling at one thing hey this might be
the big big big thing for the next two
decades comma
99 of these things are gonna fail so
what's the entry point you know it's a
very tricky game i mean i totally agree
so what gives you the bravery to jump
and say i'm gonna try this out because
that first step is the dangerous step
because as you say it's so nascent right
now that you don't know where it's going
to go we've all got some ideas and we'll
get into that but how why did you take
the first step or how
lack of fear
you know i think with v friends it was
uh right before valentine's day i
remember so it was like maybe the 13th
or the 12th and i just had that eureka
moment i felt at that point i was ready
i knew enough
i knew exactly what i wanted to do dutch
auction on
chain you know uh utility based heavily
to hedge
you know the fact that i wanted to build
a
40-year intellectual property
that i'm going to do cartoons of video
games and sweatshirts and toys and you
know i i jumped in because i knew i
wasn't gonna lose and more and more
importantly much more importantly
i knew that i was willing to die before
i would let the people that invested it
early on lose
i knew that i was willing to shut down
everything
that if god forbid i didn't see
something or something was off that i
was willing to stake my entire
reputation on the project and that is
why i did it because i knew that i would
go to zero
have a far less
fancy life
to rest assured that the people that
went in
won
because this is a key point that i've
got with the spaces many people come to
the nft space to extract value
they think they've got a community the
first thing they do is that as opposed
to having any utility or any community
value proposition they just take money
out the community and we saw that with
like kings of leon um and a few of these
suddenly it collapses right because what
you've just done is take money from the
community give nothing in return apart
from given one single person products
and the idea is you have to build value
you have to build real meaningful
community value for it to have true
value that's right i think that
i was very comfortable with some of the
cynicism from the og
nft community when i announced it or
when i launched it because i understood
i didn't have the audacity to think that
they should have spent 20 or 30 or 15 or
10 hours on who i am what my track
record was how i've done things
you know i'm stunned by people's anger
you're not entitled to people putting in
that kind of work and i knew that it
would take five hours ten hours for
somebody to really understand that over
the last 15 years all i've done is the
reverse all i've done is given more to
my community than i've asked for in
return
which is an incredible formula for your
business that's been your business model
it's been my business
and and it's been based on this concept
of 5149 i have always felt that i was
talented at such a level that if i was
able to get 49 of the value of any
interaction that i would have plenty
and so it's an incredibly
simplistic mindset but it's it's it's
allowed me to have a far better
reputation with anybody who's actually
ever interacted with me
than the perception
and and that's what one can only hope
for too many people
walking around earth right now who have
good reputations on social media but not
with the people that actually interact
with them and i love
what my reputation is with the people
that interact with me and i knew that i
was going to bring that to the table and
i knew what is happening now was going
to happen which was 60 days
100 days 600 days
a thousand days later one by one the
individuals that took a [ __ ] on me or
who spit at it
you know
if they had the humility and if they
were gracious would come out and say and
i've been i've been incredibly flattered
it mean i'll say this it means the world
to me when a stranger shits on me
and says i'm the worst i don't even hear
it but i'd be lying if i didn't say and
i don't get the accolades either when
people think i'm the great i don't get
high but i i'd be lying if i didn't say
when somebody comes out and says i
thought you were a fraud or this was a
rug pull or a cash grab or you were just
another one of those and i've had a
little bit of time to look into this wow
or kudos or hat tip it means a lot it
means a lot to win someone's respect who
has a bad
feeling towards you and i enjoy that
feeling and people have got to
understand that you particularly put
yourself out as the product
so if you were to betray that you've
lost all trust and integrity in which
case your brand goes to zero so you're
highly incentivized to absolutely make
sure it goes as well as you possibly can
nothing can all be guaranteed as a
success the day before v friends launch
is i'm at the height of my financial
life
and that is completely built on my
reputation yeah
so i think to your point it's very clear
to me that you have a good sense of this
um
i had everything to lose but that was
the best part because i knew
what i said to you was true which was
there just was no outcome it's for some
miraculous reason 87 things went poorly
that led to a [ __ ] show
i was going to give everybody their
money back there's no outcome where my
reputation doesn't trump my bank account
and that's not saying you think that the
tokens can go up or down in value but it
means that you're there to guarantee the
rug pull that this is not that it
doesn't go wrong
whatever the reverse in this space of a
rug pull is is exactly how i went into
it which was i was gonna backstop it
financially
if something if again many things out of
my control went horribly wrong that i
couldn't have saw
i also know that i'm gonna make empathy
elephant and patient pig
and you know entrepreneur elf
literally commercial successes talk me
through the vision so you you create the
characters
you create the nfts
what are you going to do with all of
this where is this going for you next
phase i'm going to build disney over the
next 40 years i'm going to make people
care about my characters whether through
video game form
whether through book form whether
through
iphone game whether through vr
whether through commercials
tv
brand deals cereal candy
you know i am an incredibly
well positioned individual
to do so because of the way my actual
business life works so what you've
essentially done is lay out your stall
for a vision of the future to say look
there's a great business opportunity
here to do this
people can get a share in the value of
that network that you're going to create
and then you're going to go and create
that and that's right if it works this
one this was the this was the first time
that people had an opportunity to invest
in me in theory right
and and for me what i really like this
is where nfts really caught my attention
let's say we're trucking along my intent
is that these are the original disney
cells let's start there right no there's
no commercial rights there's not you
know these are disney cells right the
original drawings that's why i drew them
i wanted it to have the real provenance
like truth right
these characters from my drawings will
develop into things that are far more
beautiful for film and television and
and merchandise right
in 12 years if i'm trucking along with
this project and i don't like the price
of the tokens i don't feel that my
community has extracted enough value
that the rookie cards are just not worth
as much as i had hoped for them even
though the enterprise is making hundreds
of millions of dollars in these other
activities in merchandise ip extraction
well i i am in control i can do a movie
deal
that is direct to you know that has huge
economics finally it hits i have my big
thing and if i decide
that i want to give 20 of the box office
to my token holders i can
you know and that kind of that kind of
power
to support your community
is extremely attractive to me because i
have the ability to make
this community whole if i don't like
where it's at now the lucky part is for
me is i did a lot of things
well
and jim and everybody at nft42 deserves
a lot of credit i did a lot of listening
i'm very happy i went dutch auction it
you know it allowed a lot of people to
get in i also like that it was that my i
had a glitch with my meta mask and the
gas fees looked high and because it was
a dutch auction a lot of things started
tracking down
i also like the fact that the far
majority of the people that actually
bought it were people that i put into a
discord months earlier educated them on
eth metamask you know open c
so what i have now is a stunning
percentage of the people holding the
tokens were non-crypto native
individuals
you know i'm very proud especially as i
watch all of them now diversify and get
into all these other projects
there's not a lot of people in 2021
who've brought brand new people to the
space
you know and i i take a lot of pride in
that i think that is really going to be
my legacy
over the next 24 months between my
public appearances
where my brand goes into different
places my impact of working with brands
with vayner nft my consultancy company
you know i i i have a lot of pride in
this statement i think i'll be at the
top of the list of the humans that
brought more people into the space which
inherently helps everyone how are you
thinking through when i look at this
space i think the biggest thing that's
coming is community tokens overall
so even when i look at you know facebook
dm that's coming right people think it's
this stable coin it's actually the
world's biggest community token yeah it
won't go up and down in value with the
value of the network but that's where
this is all going right you can coalesce
massive groups of people
with a community token share the
economics and it drives network effects
all they want to do is promote you and
the product
in theory it's actually a very
simplistic concept right if you
decentralized well what's left
the humans that create the demand and
the community that
it supports
that's right
right so for me
all those people
who cashed in for a quick this is why
patience is the greatest gift
i to me
my ability to run a marathon versus a
sprint
my comp think about think about i mean
the sheer economics of the people that
have already won on my
play and i haven't even launched the
three super conferences yet and all the
things i'm actually doing you know
hopefully in three or four years to your
point i fully agree with you hopefully
in three or four or five years when that
becomes more obvious to everyone my
friend and becomes more real
you know if i have a project under my
under my belt that created extraordinary
returns for the people
you know that made that bet it surely
puts me in a very good spot
to get to the next level of scale and i
fully believe that's what's going to
happen and i feel like the trust of
sovereign nations to create currencies
that happen long long long ago
will now happen around human individuals
yeah i totally agree and around these
communities and i and i think it
disrupts so many people it takes out so
many middlemen on route
and the other thing it and and generates
puts that money back into the community
and it just creates
very powerful
future economics for all of this when
everybody's incentives are aligned
that that's extraordinary what it's
going to do it's extraordinary what it
what it requires is the people
that start the movement the ip the music
the book
the recipe whatever it is
it requires them to be able to create
demand and ltv
and so i think one thing that a lot of
artists need to be very careful of is
this sounds tremendous
everybody in the middle is getting cut
out and i i in my community get to have
the economics
there is an incredible skill
that is associated with actually
building a community there is a there is
a level of
bringing such deep inherent value and
then by the way and you know this
don't get confused by following count if
you're just extremely attractive and
that's why you have 11 million followers
on instagram
that's not necessarily going to put you
in a position to create an economy
around yourself
you know for me i was very unique i've
spent the last decade
creating free content that has impacted
people
to
win mentally or financially without very
little
ask in return creates a very different
relationship than somebody who if i was
had great abs and never had a shirt on
and had a 10 of 10 face
you know that's a very different
relationship
that's right because it's not adding
necessarily value it's adding pleasure
because somebody wants to see somebody
with good acts but yeah and escapism is
an incredible value proposition
i will tell you in my most stressed days
going to netflix and watching stand-up
comedy brings me incredible value
yeah it really does
i'm just not sure that i want to support
dave chappelle's economy
not because by the way i think jay
chappelle is and the reason i use him as
an example he might be one of the most
thoughtful bright comedians i've ever
seen in my life i just don't have a
great sense of is he willing to put in
the time to his community ex you know
create access
create a monster monster relationship
graph
know how to build intellectual property
that is scales outside of him those are
very very very very different realities
because most people have a one-way
relationship with that audience they
push content out
and then get paid for it that's it
that's right and and and don't forget
what famous people are accustomed to
they're accustomed to taking a big bag
up front
and then an organism in the middle is
actually figuring out those economics of
leveraging the upfront
right you know what's been so great
about my career is i've always done
things for myself but even when i play
that role let's say in my book life
i always know that i don't like my deal
with my book publisher
but i've used it historically as an
upfront cash flow model for me because i
was pouring all my money back into
building my businesses
but today as somebody who just finished
their final book of their book deal
harper collins is going to have to come
to me with a very aggressive offer to
take me out of the equation of launching
my next book as an nft
you know
i mean why i mean for because they're
instead of them being my upfront money i
can easily you know nfts are absolutely
now the the funding mechanism
to projects well it gets rid of vcs
essentially like we i think
we've raised all the money we've ever
raised real vision about 60 million
dollars has only come from our members
we've never taken outside capital
there's no reason to that's the power of
community now if you tokenize you have
direct access to the capital of your
community
what i love about it too and it was
funny where my brain just went
i'll go there again because i don't
think people talk about this i love this
idea of coming through for my community
no matter what let me give an example
this is very interesting actually
i have hated raising money my whole life
i've done it a couple times for a couple
startups and it's been the worst
experience i don't like asking for money
so much so
that both times
rezzy and empathy
rezzy the restaurant app i sold to amx
and empathy the wine brand dtc that i
sold the consolation both times i
secretly had a bank account that had the
entire capital raise sitting in cash
in in case i have to so
what i like about nfts though is i would
feel much more comfortable doing that
i'll tell you why once they own the
token i can work for them forever
i could fail on my book on my restaurant
on my startup and still come back and
say hey
if you still hold the empathy wine token
go connect in here and now you're
getting 20 of my speaking fees in 2024
like i'm in control of always making
good so i think people like myself
organizations like me
humans like me actually are in a much
better place because i never
ever felt great about raising capital
but selling an nft that has a
functionality to something i'm doing
that even if that thing fails
my ability to come back and say i'm
gonna do this is an incredible
incredible opportunity but the other
thing that somebody brought up to me the
other day is the fact that because it's
on the blockchain this stuff never dies
so you're 90 years old and you're still
owing value
to those nfts
it's quite scary
it's literally the best i i'll tell you
one of the things i'm most excited about
most excited about is the idea of
buying
some nf nfts that launched today
in 31 years
like i've always talked about
refurbishing old ip what if ford api
club
doesn't make it
and let's say it's dormant for 20 years
no different than the a team or happy
days or smurfs
you know it's been so hot during this
special year for nfts that i bet you in
22 years if i bought that up
and refurbished it and reminded people
of the great year of 2021 the way toys
work the way nostalgia works so i'm
already i mean it's the reason i'm
buying up curio cards right
they're incredibly underpriced
in my opinion for the ability to
eventually and maybe something pops up
because the archaeologists are still
looking but as of this point
if that truly is the first nft project
the you know compare those prices to
crypto punks
there's an incredible opportunity of
that being in you know and by the way
that might be somebody in 11 years
saying wait a minute
and they're the madonna they're the
michael jordan they're the lebron james
they're the whoever of that era saying
wait a minute curio cards is first this
is the coolest i'm putting this on all
my clothes i'm getting a tattoo
you know the post malone a little oozy
vert of that moment or the kardashians
of that moment
you know
and that's amazing because that's the
beauty of
authenticity on the blockchain and also
the policy the the the the value of
nostalgia considering we've just had the
biggest age demographic of all time the
millennials now we've seen what the
boomers did to anything
versus their generation
these millennials this is their prime
time right they're earning their money
they've got their group of pop stars
that they love that they grew up in all
of this is going to be worth a fortune
to them in future because it'd be the
story of their lives i think that's
right i think that you're also talking
about gen z coming up the ranks where
they only know
about spending money
to get a fortnight skin to get a roblox
upgrade to get madden points to get mba
2k points to
there isn't a 15 year old or under
in the world right now
that doesn't understand the logic of mom
dad give me your credit card i would
like to spend actual money to get these
points in this environment where i have
my social
currency i have my identity wrapped up
in and if i can get you know they would
rather get a hundred dollar skin in that
game than a hundred dollar pair of
sneakers they'd probably want both
because they're kids
once that hit scale that was always my
point about social media my point in
2012 to a lot of people was you do
understand there's an entire generation
right now being affected and they're
going to be 24 years old and they won't
know any different and that's where
we're living now in 2021.
you know we've got an entire generation
of 24 year olds who started with social
media at 11 or 12 or 13
it's just their life
nfts are just the completely scaled
version of video game and gaming
dynamics
that have completely and utterly
penetrated everybody on earth under 15
so they'll only live in this reality
when they're 25. so that's the next
question is you're obviously thinking
i'm knowing you for the short period
that i've known you you're absolutely
thinking about the metaverse as well
because that's where this is all going
how are you thinking of that
because obviously you're creating these
characters they're not going to live on
a cinema screen they're going to live in
the metaverse that's right and and i'm a
big fan of both you know i'm a big and
versus or guy you know i want you know
one thing for everybody who's listening
because i know a lot of people can tune
in given our two worlds
this concept of ore is devastating
you know when when you're long bitcoin
and you should be but if you're spending
most your time [ __ ] on any
alternative coin that's bad energy spent
i'm watching all these people in nfts
saying kumbaya kumbaya but the second
that somebody promotes an identity that
they're not a part of they [ __ ] on it
and it's so fascinating to me wrong
it's wrong it's just it's a bad way to
play
uh it doesn't work out in the end
nonetheless
uh you're exactly right and the way that
i'm doing that is i'm already you know
i've done
a couple of interviews in the metaburst
i'm spending a ton of time with
uh
facebook i think facebook is way out in
the head talk about a potential
underpriced arbitrage i've been talking
about this forever facebook they're so
far ahead and if you know who andrew
bosworth is baz who's leading kind of
the oculus bra like he is going to
introduce me to him today actually
amazing he's
so talented it's scary he's truly one of
the few people i've met in business in
25 years that i would blindly bet on
that gives me triple confidence
i you know i've been looking at facebook
at 375 dollars a share lately and again
i told you earlier i'm not that guy i
don't understand wall street i don't
understand this but knowing what they're
up to there i'm like hmm
they are so far ahead they own instagram
so they have this contemporary scaled
machine
it if they nail their timing it's going
to be a windfall so you're right i've
been spending you know a ton of time
with them
you know to give you a little exclusive
quite a bit about how v friends shows up
in that world and i'll be there two
years early because the space is big but
what i'm really good at and what i
really do focus on is timing so when i
say i'll be there two years early i'll
be flirting with it i'm already having
metaverse oculus deception like i'm
already doing plenty of things
the thing that everybody saw for me
in january this year where i'm like tada
nfts that may be three years away
because i don't like to do that
until i think that there is a scaled
consumer event going on
why because if people jump in
when you're too early you lose the most
and here's why
when you're too early you're going to
lose on the economics and the
opportunity and then the reason i say
you lose the most
is because then it really hurts three
years later when it happens yeah exactly
right i saw a kid tweet today he said
guys i'm really mentally struggling i
had a 35 000 position on axi infinity
three four six months ago whatever he
said he goes it's worth you know 1.3
million dollars right now and i'm a
young kid with no money i'm really
hurting
and it just it hit me about timing you
know which is like and and really this
one's different because social
when i was talking about social it was
about building brand the most important
thing in the world
the problem with nfts is you're talking
about transactional money so the way
that a sentence maybe even a comment we
make in here the way that triggers
really scares me it makes me not want to
talk you know i really don't i i i don't
i'm very fearful of the platform that i
have
i have i
and even though i say 98 are going to
fail and even though i say every day
please only put money into this that you
can afford to lose this is an extremely
high risk category right now for a
million reasons regulation supply and
demand issues timing we're in internet
95 99 like it's early
even though i say all these things i
know if i say hey i like fame ladies
squad and these are really good art and
i love more female projects that
potentially hundreds if not thousands of
people go and buy them blindly even
though ev please do your own homework
i'm always wrong i say all these things
at nausea but people don't hear it i
have the same issue and it's really it's
scary and yet that's
i've taken very responsibly to say
listen i don't know i think i know and
i've got a lot of experience but i don't
know and i could be wrong and i'm wrong
a lot
and you know because you know people
carry their hopes and dreams
particularly in a space like this that's
so new and moving so fast
people really want to be involved and i
get that but you know as you say you've
got to do your own homework there's a
way to be involved right there's an
incredible way it's called spend money
that you can afford to lose i mean wax
is an incredible blockchain with
incredibly good nostalgic ip with very
low costs you don't have to go buy a 3
000 eth you know launch token or 800
you know 0.35 as we saw with stoner cats
or even with d friends was very
expensive because i attached
you know what in essence gonna end up
being
15 million dollars worth of three-year
events for me so i really need to
generate dollars and and there'll be
more i think as people dissect the
friends over the next three or four
years
six to 12 months i think more people
will look at it and understand it and i
think you'll have more expensive nft
projects because it's not just about the
art right now you have a flooding of
people that have copied board api clubs
naming dynamics and now you have
skinny
snail thursday club and you have like
extremely happy hamster
crew and you know and everyone's and
you've got and there's very little
underneath other than we'll let you
share in the economics well guess what
owning fifty percent of something that's
worth zero is zero
ninety-nine percent of these people are
not going to be able to make their ip
mean something and what is bad about
this space is everybody will lump
everything in together so we know one of
these big projects is going to go to
zero correct
and they will go to you and say see gary
it's all a bunch of [ __ ] you're just
conning people
and this is the annoying thing and i'll
say
if i was making content in 1999 when i
told everybody the internet was the most
important thing that had ever happened
in our lives and the stock market
collapsed and it was death on wall
street and everybody who invested in
pets.com shares went to zero
i would say
okay but guess what amazon's five bucks
a share i think you should buy it yeah
exactly right
because when you look back on the chart
of the nasdaq back in 2000 and it's feel
really dramatic it now looks like a
little small bump on the road
because what came after it was in that
and i think what keeps me calm at night
lets me put my head on my pillow is
there is no way nfts or if by the way
the word nft could change that's how
early we are oh yeah you know we called
we called social media web 2.0 right we
we called the internet the information
superhighway we used to say go to http
colon www like
i don't care what you call it i can tell
you right now that in 2039
people will use digital assets the way
they use physical assays to communicate
to each other and there's no doubt in my
mind and physical assets will also be
recorded on the blockchain as tokens as
well so
we could all buy a property together in
manhattan that's a 50 million dollar
apartment and share amongst 100 people
and you know all of this changes
dramatically
in a real you know your your point there
was funny back to aaron battalion his
first point was lisa's mortgages like
when he was explaining the smart
contract it just blew my mind i'm like
this is incredible like yeah i don't
think we've even begun to to innovate
how about this how about if you're lucky
enough today to sit with an incredibly
unusual property like a home let's just
say you're an extremely wealthy person
and you have just a very unique home
well i think you blockchain it and when
you sell it
you put in a royalty that says you make
two percent on every transaction of this
home in perpetuity
like i
and
you know maybe eventually why wouldn't
you like i can tell you right now if you
decided to sell it let's say we became
friends over next 15 years and i wanted
to buy it for some reason right
when you're like hey by the way there's
a one percent royalty in the contract
it's not going to matter to me
not but i'll tell you what's going to
matter to your great great great
grandchildren when it changes hands for
the fifth time and for some reason they
get a 800 000 check in the mail or an 80
000 check in the mail they're going to
be awfully happy with great great great
great great
granddaddy figuring out why he
understood the blockchain the other
thing i'm looking at is also ip rights
so let's say you're a pop star you've
just started your career
and to your community you sell the first
year's ip rights
you share in them
and you they pick the song that they
think is going to be a hit there's going
to be millions of people on tick tock
trying to explode the content getting it
everywhere because that's their job
in that i could i i couldn't agree more
early on back in december january
early on six months ago i was trying to
explain it to friends i was like okay
i had one friend very into music i said
you know how you like find new bands and
you love that you take pride in it and
when they get big you get upset and
they've sold out i go you're not going
to care you're not going to be upset
anymore because what do you mean i go
let's play it out let's say nirvana
decided to give up 20
of their ip
in nft form to fund them so they didn't
have to sign a record deal
let's say today
that you were one of those earliest fans
in the grunge movement in seattle
and you bought some tokens
let's say today every day you wake up
and you look at your bank account and
spotify because teen spirit is being
streamed as many times as it is every
day and you own 0.3
of the royalty that they're getting
this is going to be the greatest
revolution of people being able to
support artists they loved
and actually make incredible economics
for being right
but also it makes culture an investment
and it's also because of that by the way
by the way let's stop there right now
i just want to make sure everybody who's
listening and obviously if you're
listening at least half of you because
i'm sure i'll bring plenty of people to
this your your incredibly handsome smart
host here
just said the only thing that actually
matters and it's the reason i'm so in
the only thing i've ever understood is
the stuff that's unseen
the reason the black and white of
finance world never clicked for me is
because i was the best at gray and i
understood it so well that it just
became my passion and my
my
obsession when when our great host here
says what he just said and that's why i
had to jump in
and there's a lot of ramifications about
this by the way
you know there's a whole
counter
to what we're about to say that will
play out 20 years from now that will
change the world in a way that you can't
imagine
the purity of culture has been
incredible because it wasn't
economic between the end audience and
the person there was always something in
between
but over the next 30 years here's what
will happen first in the first 10 to 15
years is what we just talked about
culture will become
financialized
value community brand it will be it will
become more literal
the back half of that 30-year period
people will start to gain that and the
purity of it will actually have an issue
and that'll be very interesting to watch
what that actually manifests
but let there be no confusion
that statement was the most important as
much as i've been yapping
the tokenization of culture is exactly
right it's the only thing i've been
thinking about the whole time
and uh
it's gonna be a big [ __ ] deal
it really is it's the biggest thing i've
looked at this whole crypto space i've
been in it since 2012
and
i've been excited about the whole thing
and all of it
is less exciting than this tokenization
of culture the kind of nft
plus community stuff that's coming plus
the metaverse is like the biggest thing
i've literally ever seen i think that's
right and i think you know i
i don't know if i have more respect for
the og or enthusiastic bitcoin community
you know they get mad at me when i do
podcasts but i always say to them please
don't be mad i'm genuinely i'm actually
complimenting i think it's so big
that i'm just curious what sovereign
nations are gonna do i don't know what
else to tell you it's you know it's it's
actually the greatest compliment it's
not an insult i don't not not get it i
think i get it so much
that i'm like curious because i think
it's you know a big big big deal and
really cool and i love that
but i do think that
what is a far bigger
conversation
is the tokenization of the gray of
society which i think is a good trillion
dollar industry and i think we're in the
pre-dawn of it and i think the cat's out
of the bag and i think these next 30
years are going to be iconic and
hopefully we'll both be at the forefront
of it yeah and hopefully for me i'll be
honest with you i for a long time ago
realized i was going to make
all the money i ever wanted for myself
because the truth is the only number i
ever had in my mind was 100 000 a year i
came from very humble beginnings that
was the only number that i really
thought about
i definitely want to be at the forefront
but i want to bring the most people to
the forefront so it completely changes
their lives and i you know one of the
reasons i chose this podcast out of all
the ones that i got bombarded with is
uh
i i really appreciate what i think
you're doing for your community as well
and i understand how you navigate which
is probably why you understand how i not
navigate
and i uh and i cheer for people like
that so thank you for having me on i
hope this discussion helped some people
and uh this was fun yeah thank you for
coming as well and look you know i think
this is really important for people to
understand what is going on is a big
opportunity and it doesn't matter if
you're rich
or poor
everybody can participate
look at axi look at board api club these
are things that were incredibly
inexpensive and this is a very
this is a
transcending
half decade in front of us around this
with with the potential of an 18-month
winter
within it which is going to be an
incredibly fun thing to watch of people
who they have conviction and who doesn't
and so i just wish everybody great luck
but most importantly do homework do not
be influenced by me him
or anybody else do your homework do your
homework rely on your strengths make
your own decisions and play with things
that you can afford to lose
i i think the opportunity is real as
well
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you